California passed an outrageous law
declaring their whole state to be a
sting singer for criminal illegal
Democrats decided to shield and shelter
look look wait you have criminals and
let me begin by wishing you a beautiful
like look you remember this do you
remember and they say the noise causes
cancer you tell me that one okay all
right
you know the thing makes it is soda and
of course it's like a graveyard for
birds
the missiles fired last night at US and
our allies were paid for with the funds
made available by the last
administration the regime also greatly
tightened the reins on their own country
and he just gave Conan a medal and a
plaque and it's really and I actually
think Conan knew exactly what was going
on
[Applause]
[Music]
unfortunately you put the wrong people
in a couple of positions and they leave
people for a long time that shouldn't be
there and all of a sudden they're trying
to take you out with [ __ ] okay at
some point in the future we're to look
back and say how did we do it without
space the Vice President will serve as
the council's chair
the privatization of certain aspects is
going to be very it's going to play a
very crucial role don't you think they
are truly into it I will say that's not
easy because everybody wants to be on
this board people that you wouldn't have
believed loved what we're doing so much
they want to be as some of the most
successful people in the world what be
on this point the human soul yearns for
discovery by unlocking the mysteries of
the universe we are locked truths within
ourselves that's true how old is she
that's good but what is your response
there to greet me Evan Time magazine
what did you hear from were other world
leaders and business leaders who said
that they think that she has no my dad
was actually but I would have loved to
have seen her speak I did not and it's a
wall not a good looking wall it's a wall
it's got 36 doors at at big doors very
big doors and they never put the doors
on so it's 38 miles with 36 doors that
you can drive a truck through there's
only one problem they never put the
doors on it so we're putting the doors
on it or even better maybe not putting
any doors I said maybe you do it without
the doors
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]